what's going on you guys lord addict
here
our second playthrough of death's door
today we're going to be talking a lot
about you know what's going on
necessarily with this game so far we
have went into another realm we have
defeated a boss
we've opened up a couple pathways but we
ain't really done nothing anything
relevant
anything substantial in this game we
came back to this room and
homeboy down there he wants us to go
talk to him
and trade in some souls it looks like so
it does look like it has
kind of that npc that was in the dark
soul games
that when you talk to them you trade
currency and then you're able to buy
certain you know items or abilities in
general
so welcome to the soul vault where would
you like to increase your combat skills
all right so it looks like it's just a
basic um
five man thing uh so you got strength
the reaper's ability to
to wield melee weapons strength that
will increase the damage done with melee
weapons as long
as well as as their reach so
i assumed like he kind of maybe jumps
into it a little bit
the reaper's ability to attack with
speed and precision
raising uh this will allow the reaper to
charge their melee attack range faster
and increase the speed at which melee
attacks can be chained together
then we got haste the reaper speed and
grace of movement
raising this will give the reaper a
greater
base speed faster dodges and less
cooldowns between dodges
and then we got the magic the reaper's
ability to harness magical powers
raising this will increase the damage
done
with magic spells and ranged abilities
so we're going to
not do nothing it looks like hold up i
need a little bit more
we ain't doing nothing man need a little
bit more
i wish they would have even told me to
come here
it's kind of a waste of time if you ask
me just a little bit
a little bit of a waste of the time
[Music]
so i don't know what i'd want to upgrade
i feel like i want to go for speed
i feel like speed's the better upgrade
[Music]
look at this dude only get hit four
times
these things are good for just one hit
that's why i like fighting
and it looks like we got the little soul
things down there
so it looks like the the whole map
returns to how it was even the
the shortcuts i don't know what happened
there
but it looks we don't have to do that
thing again so that's good
trying to remember exactly where to go
here
let's go up here is there like a map
like a mini map
no i mean that's not a bad thing
[Music]
we'll just keep traveling man we don't
really need upgrades
right now i would say because i'm not
really having too much of an issue
with the game
but we are gonna have to upgrade that
momentarily
that that's definitely a thing okay so
we've been there before i remember that
there was that little building up there
that said
something about a clone of it or
something like that i can't remember
came across this earlier in the game i
didn't see
[Music]
okay let's go back up
that's just going back to the the
beginning area
i still want to know how to kill these
how to get in these rooms
[Music]
the roly-poly thing
those aren't too hard to kill
got these one one hits
all you got to do is make sure that
roller pulley can't really do too much
it seems like if you hit him in the back
it does a little bit more damage
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that was unfortunate
[Music]
come on
gotta be quick with it man
oh yeah here's the the witch again
[Music]
gotta be quick with it man
ow
gotta dodge that fire first
[Music]
the fire's not too complicated a dog
all right so we got oh god
damn it
[Music]
that was that was unfortunate
it was unfortunate but we're just gonna
go right back there
you know i just be letting
them get too many hits in that's what it
is
run down here
i might want to go ahead and just take
my time
i'm thinking about running past them but
i think that might blow up in my face
don't want to run past them and then
they come up behind me
i already have the encounter that we
have to fight anyway
not get hit by that dude again
i like how they like come off of
whatever
that shell that they're on
it's really cool how they just fall off
of it
so let's let's kill this mage as fast as
we can
we're gonna we're gonna do things slow
this time
or are we gonna get hit by that
[Music]
you can only really shoot three either
back to back
[Music]
got to be quick man
already been hit once
oh my god
[Music]
i wonder if they could fall off the mat
oh roly-polies
[Music]
let's just take these things out first
okay so the royal playlist can fall off
[Music]
i just gotta worry about
the mage hitting me from that range
there we go that was a little close man
i got hit three times in that game
a rule off once and i got hit twice
all right let's see what's going on over
here
i don't know that's supposed to be a
checkpoint i don't know why he didn't
save
oh my god
this is a really bad idea
i'm not trying to mess with none of
these people
[Music]
come on
wow they hit me through the wall
i hope i kept that checkpoint
let's go ahead and just go upgrade
i knew i shouldn't have fought those
people but i did anyway
all right so it's like i said i want to
upgrade the speed first
i've always i enjoy more of a speed type
of
of a level more than anything go back to
the lost semi
symmetry or cemetery the lost cemetery
i'm not fighting under you guys
i don't want none of the smoke i don't
have to fight you guys
[Music]
oh what is this it's a boss isn't it
oh snap it's a boss
i wonder if i could beat this on my
first go the guardian of the door
what are you guarding or what door
tell me oh
i'ma hit you with this
oh you teleport
[Music]
oh look at you
got a little bit of speed to you
[Music]
three three hits
oh my god
come on you could do better than that
[Music]
it's going oh what is this
what is this
[Applause]
try again
try again buddy oh you're hitting
projectiles
i see you
maybe i should invest a little bit into
that boat
[Music]
oh i see what you're doing you're gonna
do that again
oh projectiles and the laser beam
unfortunately for you all of them are
pretty easy to dodge
oh projectile what is he doing now
oh wait
oh the laser beam and the projectiles
done over finished
make sure it don't fall on
it's a pretty nice little fight if i say
so myself
nice little fight man i had to give him
credit for that
that's where the graveyard dude is what
does this do
all right so
what does this lead to because i'm
curious
what this leads to
[Music]
how many of these do i have
i don't want to use it if i don't need
to
that's definitely a key that goes there
[Music]
what is this
you found an incense this was very
strong
all right so i found an incense
i still don't know what that does though
probably put it somewhere
oh this is that thing
is that thing that was crossing the
bridge in the first episode
what is that
oh hello flingly butchered that sorry
about the crack on the head but i needed
that soul
oh that's the thing that knocked us out
i see i was a reaper just like you
years ago my simon evaded capture it
took many months to track it down to
this location
upon arrival i discovered it to somehow
pass through the store
do you know where we are fingerling
dead stores the name of the game
the end point for all life i thought it
was just a legend
as you know all doors are powered by the
energy of souls perhaps with the truly
momentum amount of power even this one
could be forced open
sadly the stole uh the soul i stole from
you was not enough
[Music]
i'm afraid that our fates are very much
intertwined affluently
for with your assignment incomplete your
death is now and if
it may be oh man without the soul that
now
rises behind the door you are trapped
just like me this dude literally gonna
steal our stuff trap us in this
in this internal thing because we don't
have the soul to stop us from aging
and then say it's it's our fault pretty
much
however fortunate still upon us the
curse line is hidden to the reapers
somehow
untouched by the law of nature the
creatures
here have the petition to live vast
beyond their years growing even larger
and more powerful
i know three such beings on these
islands with combined souls could
grant us enough power to wedge this door
open
to the north there's an old witch
obsessed with escaping the clutches of
death
beyond the force to the east a a
self-proclaimed queen
rules over the uh the ruins of a flooded
cathedral
and on top of the mountain to the west a
beast of untold primal and vicious with
no
wants or desire am i'm truly starting to
enslave you fledgling
but in my advance advanced years my body
grows with
weary your path is now on your own
either venture to the lands and reap
these giant souls or choose in action
and suffer the same
fit this old fool you're the reason i'm
suffering that
oh my god i don't like how extra he was
being
on the reason that
like he was acting like like we like
someone else stole the soul
and that's the reason that we have to
deal with it
where did this go it's now the
checkpoint
all right so it connects with the the
graveyard
okay
let's go back down
oh
oh i kind of feel bad when i hit those
people when they crying
let's run down all right here's the
giant bridge that
thing knocked us out and came through i
really hope he's the last boss
because that was ridiculous what he did
and that my friends is what we're gonna
end episode two uh we beat the second
boss
probably gonna go down here and see
about
unlocking something else on the next
episode i don't know if any
those three individual beasts that we
have to win after i don't know if
they have any specific order we have to
go in
but i'm kind of curious on that i'd like
to fight the witch first but
if i can't fight the witch first i have
to go fight another one before i can
fight the witch
or maybe the witch is the last one if
there is an order then
obviously i would have to come across
that when i come across that
but episode 3 will be out soon
appreciate you guys gaming ad
lord addicts out be sure to catch the
iron lures podcast at 1 p.m eastern
every sunday we'll be going over
everything about gaming you could think
of we cover all the platforms
but until next time guys addicts out